Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Dr. Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
Approximately 5 months ago, we talked about
a technique called Neural Radiance Fields,
or NERF in short, where the input is the location
of the camera and an image of what the camera
sees, we take a few of those, give them to
a neural network to learn them, and synthesize
new, previously unseen views of not just the
materials in the scene, but the entire scene
itself.
In short, we take a few samples, and the neural
network learns what should be there between
the samples.
In comes a non-continuous data, a bunch of
photos, and out goes a continuous video where
the AI fills in the data between these samples.
With this, we can change the view direction,
but only that!
This concept can also be used for other variables.
For instance, this work is able to change
the lighting, but only the lighting.
By the way, this is from long ago, from around
Two Minute Papers episode number 13, so our
seasoned Fellow Scholars know that this was
almost 500 episodes ago.
Or, the third potential variable is time.
With this AI-based physics simulator, we can
advance the time, and the algorithm would
try to guess how a piece of fluid would evolve
over time.
This was amazing, but as you might have guessed,
we can advance time, but only the time.
And this was just a couple of examples from
a slew of works that are capable of doing
one, or at most, two of these.
These are all amazing techniques, but they
offer separate features.
One can change the view, but nothing else,
one for the illumination, but nothing else,
and one for time, but nothing else.
With the advent of neural network-based learning
algorithms, I wonder if it is possible to
create an algorithm that does all three?
Or is this just science fiction?
Well, hold on to your papers, because with
this new work that goes by the name X-Fields,
we can indeed change the time…and the view
direction...and the lighting separately.
Or, even better, do all three at the same
time.
Wo-hoo!
Look at how we can play with the time back
and forth and set the fluid levels as we desire,
that is the time part, and we can also play
with the other two parameters as well at the
same time.
But still, the results that we see here can
range from absolutely amazing, to trivial,
depending on just one factor.
And that factor is, how much training data
was available for the algorithm.
Neural networks typically require loads of
training data to learn a new concept.
For instance, if we wish to teach to a neural
network what a cat is, we have to show it
thousands and thousands of images of cats.
So, how much training data is needed for this?
And now, hold on to your papers, and…whoa…look
at these 5 dots here.
Do you know what this means?
It means that all the AI saw was five images,
that is five samples from the scene with different
light positions, and it could fill in all
the missing details with such accuracy that
we can create this smooth and creamy transition.
It almost feels like we have made at least
a 100 photographs of the scene.
And all this from 5 input photos.
Absolutely amazing.
Now, here is my other favorite example.
I am a light transport simulation researcher
by trade, so by definition, I love caustics.
A caustic is a beautiful phenomenon in nature
where curved surfaces reflect or refract light,
and concentrate it to a relatively small area.
I hope that you are not surprised when I say
that it is the favorite phenomenon of most
light transport researchers.
And, just look at how beautifully it deals
with it.
You could take any of these intermediate,
AI-generated images and sell them as real
ones and I doubt anyone would notice.
So, it does three things that previous techniques
could do one by one, but really, how does
its quality compare to these previous methods?
Let’s see how it does on thin geometry,
which is a notoriously difficult case for
these methods.
Here is a previous one.
Look.
The thick part is reconstructed correctly,
however, look at the missing top of the grass
blade.
Yup, that’s gone.
A different previous technique by the name
Local Light Field Fusion not only missed the
top as well, but also introduced halo-like
artifacts to the scene.
And, as you see with this footage, the new
method solves all of these problems really
well, and is quite close to the true reference
footage that we kept hidden from the AI.
Perhaps the best part is that it also has
an online demo that you can try right now,
so make sure to click the link in the video
description to have a look.
Of course, not even this technique is perfect,
there are cases where it might confuse the
foreground with the background, and we are
still not out of the water when it comes to
thin geometry.
Also, an extension that I would love to see
is changing material properties.
Here, you see some results from our earlier
paper on neural rendering where we can change
the material properties of this test object,
and get a near-perfect photorealistic image
of it in about 5 milliseconds per image.
I would love to see it combined with a technique
like this one, and while it looks super challenging,
it is easily possible that we will have something
like that within 2 years.
The link to our neural rendering paper and
its source code is also available in the video
description.
What a time to be alive!
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!